there is more content being produced  today in 48 hours than has been Proust  from the beginning of mankind until 2003  let's talk about that one more time from  the beginning of me icon you know the  guy took the club hit girls I mean  thought dinosaurs from the beginning of  time till 2003 that was like five  minutes ago there was this much content  produced now every 48 hours that much is  produced no wonder our kids have a Dede  poor guys what that means my friends is  one thing it is going to be difficult to  break through it's going to be difficult  to break through and it is my belief  that we're dawning an age where the only  thing that's going to break through is  quality intent actually caring about the  end user and you know why  cuz it's scalable for the first time